salut peter
ça lui en fait je vous connais qu'est ce
que tu as fait une machine à votre
demande à quoi vous parlez de quelle
machine envie de jouer avec moi
vous inquiétez pas madame jarry
[Musique]
doit altérer le sortilège qui devait
faire oublier à tout le monde que peter
parker et spider man
et maintenant nous avons des visiteurs
en provenance de tous les univers
seul peter
tu vas te lancer dans la commune
affronter des photos comment ça ils sont
tous morts en combattant spider man tu
ne peux rien y faire
je suis désolé ouais moi aussi non
ils doivent d y avoir une autre solution
c'est la seule il met notre univers en
danger
je peux pas surfer tout le monde
[Applaudissements]